so this isn't just a matter of coming in
here and dumping snow everywhere you've
changed the geometry you've removed
walls you punched you'll have been up to
some stuff for sure and those visual
cues create that curiosity the Fallen
have been up to some stuff what stuff
and the campaign that you guys are
creating the story that you're telling
with these new activities in these new
worlds that's going to pay off those
curiosities we it was really important
that we want we took you to a new place
in rise of iron yeah new new new places
to play so we wanted the player to
discover that new place and the best way
to do that was to take them through a
familiar place where they got to unlock
all this new content so while I'm
stepping in through this door we got
some I guess this is a debug build yeah
this is a working progress so you're not
meant to see the luminosity here this is
something that will correct before we
ship rise of iron but that's what
happened when we pull the curtain back
is you get to see what we see when
something is in development hashtag
gained of hashtag game dev so we're not
going to take our first step outside and
you can see that the environment has
become blanketed with snow the Fallen
our vandals not just in name they're
dismantling they're just mantling our
past yeah when when we talked about
telling the story of the iron Lords that
those the iron Lords evoke a certain
imagery to us one of warriors from the
North Col by wearing winter coats bad
double-edged battle-axes beards sorry
sardis beards that's great that's so
without the sands beards we wanted the
environments to just to really met the
iron Lords did jump up here in rien
relics in a safe place alright because
I've actually got some concepts that are
kind of a good riff on some of the
things that you're talking about so if
we can go back to our deck
you have this original concept when we
first revealed rise of iron we took a
look at this concept who created this
again this is jamie jones Jamie Joan
this was one of our first visions of
Lord Saladin as the hero his his his
wolf companions and the breach in the
wall which we've now explored on our own
and you're talking about the heroes from
the Northland yes sort of the Viking
theme and we move on from that to this
concept of the plague Lance so talk to
me a little bit about the mood that
you're looking to strike here and some
of the elements that we can see on the
screen well again that the idea of the
plaguelands was that this area had been
corrupted by something that you don't
understand and not not to give too much
of the story away but like obviously you
find this place we still wanted to be
relatable we still wanted to feel like
the Cosmodrome but one that you don't
recognize so this concept was a little
too grim because you want to you want to
go to this place and you want to you
want to stay there that is a little
gloomy for our bright hopeful future
absolutely but the that large form you
see in the background those types of
things that evoke this emotion of
discovery and fantasy we wanted to keep
that so but it routes us in the real
world when I see a beached tanker ship
like that it's obvious to me that I'm on
earth I'm not exploring some snowy
wasteland far across the solar system
you know I'm not on you know like a
frozen saturn moon i'm here on earth and
this is where human society came
crushing to a halt and it's relatable
but it's made strange over time and even
more so now that we've kind of come to
think of the Cosmodrome is familiar and
you can see in the trees there those
diamond shapes you know we see evidence
of the seva outbreak but this concept is
a little bit more colorful feels a
little bit more like destiny and there's
a lot more evidence of siva in its final
form right right this this is a this is
actually really close to what we we sort
of ended up with in the in the plague
land so
and and it's and it's pretty clear see
was taken hold taken over you over this
environment and you're able add a little
bit more caller seva the seva stocks are
red yeah so it stands out as a sort of a
stark warning against the snow it's it's
pretty hideous and beautiful at the same
time and it feels like a technological
spiderweb which you know somebody who
hates spiders it definitely kind of it
sends it sends a shiver up my spine and
then this is not a concept this is an
actual view in game and this is where we
are now so let's continue our
exploration of the space and I'll get
oriented here and oh yeah this is a this
this space is called the divide in the
game we call it internally we called the
graveyard okay which is now much more
appropriate since it's got the the old
devil devil walker that he fought many
many many times indeed and this you know
some backstory for this space is that
this was actually the first place that
we did an art test early on when we
wanted to we knew we wanted to spend a
lot of our time on the new new play
glance but we wanted to make sure that
we could capture this snowy feel over
the rest of the the reprise cosmic races
and this was our first test so when we
said that destiny would be a dynamic
world a world that would change over
time a world that would react to the
things that you do and now we're really
starting to make good on that promise
because I can't tell you how many times
I've killed that tank and there it
finally lies dead in its final resting
place I want you guys to join me over
here if you could because first of all I
need help because sufficient at me and
second of all we've got an outbreak of
Siva over here and I'd love for you to
come back to me what over here d here we
go I got bad guys are there you go ok so
talk to me about this Eva outbreak
because this this these are the red
tendrils that we saw in that concept
this looks to be just erupting out of
the ground here right so the first thing
is that this is just kind
how we wanted to present this to the
player where the player is discovering
siva there seem they're starting to see
hints of it throughout the world and
then they they kind of find the source
this is a we'll just say I don't want to
give too much of the story way this is a
key player on team evil all right okay
we got and one that salad and might have
a little secret about as well one maybe
of single-handedly created a new golden
age I don't know something something
along those lines so okay so Siva is a
self-replicating machine manipulating
technology okay cool cool that and this
was contained in golden age vaults deep
beneath the cosmodrome in some place is
similar to where we discovered Rasputin
in previous adventures in destiny but
not all Golden Age technology is is
friendly or happy in the wrong hands are
under the wrong conditions this stuff
can be extremely dangerous so it's true
that a little bit of information can be
dangerous and this is not something you
want to touch you there so Keith what
was what were some of the different
considerations in terms of the art art
style because you're introducing a new
design language here to show us what
exactly is happening on Team evil t
neither yeah well so I mean Sivas is
this really interesting opportunity to
explore a whole new design and graphical
language we have elements of your
organic we have elements of the
synthetic and how they blend together
and work into the environment into the
combatants is is really interesting
visual exploration and we're working
with design to really sell these as
these are something new they act
differently they infest the world and
the enemies and all kinds of things
completely differently and the really
also the high contrast with the colors
the seva nodules to the organic stuff
yes it opens up a lot of really
interesting opportunities for us ok they
I mean the early concepts of Siva were
about like how it manipulated things and
what it looked like when it did that
once we realize we wanted to propagate
it in the environments and tell that
story
through through the levels adam williams
one of the world artists actually did
many mock-ups of what this could look
like as it consumes yeah the the space
so okay this is actually a product of
both of those things but Adam definitely
had a big hand in what this looks like
when it's cool on the environment right
we're going to move on and in order to
move on appropriately in style let's do
this guy's oh yeah I'm spawning my
gallery wing show me yours nice looking
mean let me see is it still trick indeed
it does and I stick the landing indeed
check this out you're off the if I can
do it oh I'm gonna dies no don't die
come on don't die in your stream don't
dine your strainer oh I'm dead okay no
I'm not dead can I make it back up look
at this I'm not supposed to be down here
this is dev tools dev tools at work how
did you get down there I know you need a
rope I sure do hang on i think i can get
back up there you're watching at home
you will not be able to come down here
during the actual game I need something
to kill me uh here I can help with that
can you help with that if I can tell me
in the gala wing fly
can you go to the debug cam no you know
do that again do it hang on yeah help us
on the way help is on the way so as live
once you guys spawn your galler wings
alright and do some trickin do that
trick we did yesterday where you are
where you do a sweet jump off the Canon
of the yeah well you got a line this one
up perfectly here let's see if I can do
this yeah but i didn't i didn't get the
trick out me and this look alright I'm
back topside so we're good to go again
nice work key shinee whoo I am going to
have to reinvent myself fail okay uh
we're good to go so uh let's take
ourselves further through the space here
alright well so yeah go ahead I can see
a lot of hints yeah you guys are you
guys are dropping me clues about the
devil splicers yeah and they're there
hacking apart the environment here and
what's the idea they're like what's the
what's the design goal when you're when
you're changing the environment with
these little clues here well the intent
here is that I mean this is what we're
driving right now is part of the part of
the campaign and we're it's all about
discovery I mean I players discovering
what what is actually going on and so we
wanted to tell that story as much as we
could in the environment it also is an
opportunity to change up the environment
as well like we were talking about
before in the breach so we can cut
things in half we can we can have things
fall over and just basically get a
different encounter space where where we
want mm-hmm and to give me little clues
to make me curious about what's going on
here now we can see that the devil
splicers who rule the plaguelands
they're also here so they've spilled
over the borders see are they are they
immune to a storm now indeed so my
warlock brothers and sisters you are
good to go in this new adventure we can
see they have no respect for the past
and they've even opened some new
gameplay spaces for us all right yeah
just you can see this big crack in the
wall here for cut will so what would we
find in here uh well let me I'll go take
a look and we're not supposed to go in
there here smell maintenant solo moment
yeah this is your Oklahoma moment ok
these that was that was a bad idea let's
get it to get out of here they ought to
do this way by order of command of Allah
this is not a loading zone that gillich
so you can see the devil splicers are
just teeming in there we've gotten their
Siva outbreak right here but we are not
to explore this domain today and you can
see the shanks are still hard at work
opening a geometry together creating a
new frontier for adventure and this is
where we'll send the guardians on
September 20th but not on this day i
felt that Rumble i think that's
something to go yeah is that yeah then
we're gonna get we're gonna really we
are leaving and we're going to disengage
but that will be some new places for the
players to explore later on this fall
so now we are retracing our steps if
you're familiar with the suffix prime
strike you followed this power by four
but let's come through here and let's
see what's different so rally to me
guardians and lead the way we should
make Keith lead keep your on point
you're on point Bachman all right
so this is we got a lot of non final
lighting of course yeah these are ya
these are all a work in progress yep and
while the steps that we just took we're
very much as we remember them it doesn't
take long for you to open up a new space
for us to be able to play so the
plaguelands isn't the only thing that's
new in the Cosmodrome we also have an
opportunity to hello I don't want any of
that did it watch out your gums saved
your life Kenny good fire team does the
area secure area is not secure try going
this way no I'm not are you guys going
down the stairs I'm taking the new while
we take the new way yeah they can Lily
come on we're guardians we explore I got
an invisible got it here we go he's down
that's right so you're doing all sorts
of interesting things to change this up
you're caving in the roof you're letting
us carve new paths through the landscape
you with me I'm going to let you all
yeah we're here like said like oh yeah
the world our team has had a lot of fun
crafting these faces oh well more
invisible bad guys bad bad bet
yeah they're all over the place you got
guys on your six thank you okay let's
press on through hey what's up sup new
bad guy there you go get them boys with
so we've been in this space before
fighting hive fighting wizards fighting
fallen captains but there's a new
sheriff in town and they have all sorts
of wonderful new toys
stop just stop everybody stop it I'm
trying to lead a guided tour here you're
all being a bunch of jerks everybody
just knock it off there we go I didn't
say any names I just did everybody stop
all right that's better just need some
peace and quiet I'm trying to make a
point here cuz check this out how many
times have we hacked this with our ghost
it's become hacked by something else now
so what am I seeing here that looks Eva
that definitely yeah so it does not look
friendly whatever it is so Siva is not
just something that Rex the landscape it
looks like it can coalesce into a form
of intelligence yeah the I mean it
doesn't it still it needs a mind to
control it okay um again without getting
too much into the surprises but it's um
it does the bidding you will okay we're
gonna press on oh here we go we got a
bad servitor I'm just here we go he's
not so haven't he's is all over the
place these aren't you aren't gonna like
nothing said so do the see if I have an
ally is there uh does see if I have an
ally like do different factions of
fallen fight each other do you know the
devil splicers have anyone that they're
peaceful with or did they just want to
consume everything that's a good
question i think i just keep that
question keeps on the spot you're in the
husband I'm used to seeing hive in the
space right now we have it does yes sirs
are there against everybody through
their own thing they're out to take over
everything the other starting with the
Gaza drone and Sela and they're
incredibly invasive and at least when I
play pretty darn two-foot hole see I
cleaned that up nicely you did that was
great everything we've called the
splicers many things internally so when
we've encountered hive in a lot of these
different spaces and they have
completely the devil splicers have come
in and made this their own spot now yeah
they put I've around
to where the high ever now you're gonna
find the hive in places you never saw
them before because they don't they
don't feel safe good they've been
displaced your bear off they've been
displaced from their territory from the
places where they like to hide please
keep me alive please help me help me
help me God look at that keep me safe
yep oh here we go oh this is bad there's
an interesting visual design difference
here Keith that I'd like to call out
where we fought the fallen fallen shoot
at you their weapons are very
distinctive but when you see the Fallen
captain profile and that fallen captain
has become a devil splicer it's pretty
immediately apparent right yes I mean
not only have they started to use oh
wait I don't know I don't know if you
don't if you don't think we are don't
say it no I mean not only how are they
using where you make me talk about it I
know right uh not only using see before
the environment all dirt evil ends
they're starting to modify themselves
with it yeah I've given them some rather
unique abilities and we and just even if
if they're shooting these red lasers at
you that's immediately a visual cue to
tell you that you're not fighting the
enemies that you've known in the past no
and they've got a lot of tricks up their
sleeves yeah you've probably already
seen it you noticed a couple of little
seekers seeking after you have to kill
guys and gals like that so Siva's got
some new tricks and even the servitors
are in on the action yeah actually
that's just not fair man look at this he
is is the rounds after he hires them or
even adapting to my movements so these
guys are not where is your complete if
you have a playbook for fighting the
fallen
it's time for some rewrites oh yeah cool
well this is a these are not the only
environments that you've changed
surrounding the play glance and we've
seen one of the entrances into the new
spaces that we are going to explore and
yeah like I was saying like I was saying
before I mean we wanted to spend most of
our time on all the new on all the new
spaces and and so being able to craft
new experiences in these old spaces was
definitely a goal but it's you know I
can't wait till people get to see what's
behind that yeah what's behind that
crack in the wall mm-hmm and this is not
everything so this this is not the only
area in the Cosmodrome that you've
repurposed or redesigned for rise of
iron this is just a taste these are a
few of the spaces that you'll go into
but we want to leave things for the
players to discover this is the fine
line that we straddle when we're
introducing you to a new adventure is we
want to pique your curiosity we want to
show you some of the things that you're
going to get to do but we want to leave
these things for you to discover on your
own so it's been fun to come in here and
to show you the way the Cosmodrome has
changed and maybe set you to thinking
what's the plaguelands going to be like
because as bekhab as this is and is
different as this is and as much as the
Fallen devil splicers have made this
environment a lot more dangerous the
plaguelands are much much worse right so
I think we're going to stop our
exploration here we don't get to go
through that no we're not going to go
through that I need to leave things for
the players to do they want me to show
them everything today